I am embarrassed not because i am going
to be stuttering through this entire
thing but because i am part of this
awesome world and i have not had any
sort of any sort of possible impact last
last year went to india and i had spent
three days inside of inside of inside of
a inside of a inside of a inside of a
inside of a inside of a inside of a
rural village with those people earning
a dollar a day imagine a house the size
of this floor for six people a roof a
roof a roof that is going up to your
chest you have to squat to move anywhere
there is no sanitation three days a week
you have to spread you have to spread
you have to spread you have to spread
you have to spread you have to spread
you have to spread you have to spread
the cow dung on the floor and walls as
an antibacterial a place where men in
their 40s have their faces light up
whenever they are given a second piece
of chocolate a place that where kids
have no way out I had left here feeling
impassioned to try to improve their
lives I had wanted to be able to provide
them with education sanitation and a
hope for something better but I am
embarrassed to say that soon after i had
gotten home i had forgotten
these feelings started to think about
finding a job making friends learning
finance I had let life stop me from the
impact that I wanted to have not too
long after i came across a story about a
florida starbucks about how a woman in
her 60s bought coffee for the person
behind her what followed was a two-day
750 person chain the first person bought
it for the second the second for the
third 750 times and so I started to
think whether there was an easy way for
the me perhaps you people that are not
going to people that are not going to
people that are not going to give people
that are not going to give out work
people that are not going to give our
our entire lives of solving social
problems could still have an impact I
wanted to figure out why why why why why
are people giving and what could stop
the inertia that I had experienced so I
started to so I started to like figure
this out and Stanford and Stanford and
Stanford in Stanford and Stanford in
Stanford profit beat Stanford Stanford
Stanford Stanford professor BJ Fogg has
figured out why we often fail with our
goals because they are too big and
because they are too hard goals like
solving poverty inside of India working
out five days a week flossing our teeth
every night we cannot go from zero to a
hundred miles an hour overnight we have
to start small and work
our way up we need a gradual approach we
are much better off helping people once
in our community working out one day a
week flossing a single tooth over time
we are going to have the craving to want
to do more and more we are going to help
people more often work out twice a week
three times a week plus 1 to 2 t-3 t the
other part about this is that we have to
start now research shows that as we get
older and those we get wealthier we
start to give less time and we start to
give less money the focus of our causes
also shift to be those that we are
connected to we start giving a things
like alma mater 'he's political
candidates religious institutions and we
stop giving things around poverty global
health and other social services
following this advice solving poverty
inside of India was way too big of the
first step for me and so last year I
took one small step forward and I gave
one talk to a group of youth about
overcoming challenges as a stutterer
this year I took a second step forward
and and like through and through and
through and through and through a
program here I'm help I am helping an
ex-convict Joseph Joseph on his business
let me be clear this type of behavior is
not going to solve poverty inside of
India but it is a necessary first step
it is about it is all about
is all about it is all about a change
inside of us a change towards a greater
awareness and the greater a change
towards a greater awareness radar
concern greater in a greater change
towards a greater concern for other
people and this is my challenge for all
of you today some of you are going to
some of you are going some of you are
going some of you are going some of you
are go win or some some of you are going
some of you are going or go with like to
spend your the entire life solving
social problems awesome and thank you
sincerely for those of you that are not
we can still have an impact and I'm
asking you and I'm asking you right now
today to start to build that habit to
find that something that is small to
find that something that is extremely
easy for you perhaps it's perhaps it's
perhaps it's perhaps it is perhaps it is
like going to be volunteering at or
local the boys and girls club or some
other local organization for those of us
that want to start smaller technology
has made it really easy for us apps like
charity miles you can raise money for
every mile you walk around here be be my
eyes can spend 15 seconds helping out
like a blind person navigate their
surroundings or reading or read DNA or
reading a reading A or reading a reading
a the expiration date off like a milk
carton once you start it is going to be
hard to stop your impact is going to
grow you may even inspire people to
follow after you
while we are at a school that is all
about changing lives or chain about
chain about changing lives organizations
and the world i invite you to first
start by changing one life or possibly
one organization as you start to change
the world thank you